[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
je me souviens de ma première année
d'études de droit je débarque à la fac
plein d'ambitions vous savez ce
sentiment de nouvelles vies j'étais
toute heureuse d'en finir avec le lycée
et de passer à autre chose de tourner la
page
je m'étais fait une idée merveilleuse de
l'université mais en réalité qu'est ce
que l'université s'était accentuée par
tous les témoignages de mon entourage
l'université de change la vie j'ai
rencontré mon premier amour à
l'université ou encore la fac a été le
lieu de mes réalisations jeu ticket sur
cette dernière phrase
l'université sera donc pour moi le lieu
de toutes mes réalisations
sauf que voilà les mois défilent et rien
ne se passe je délai s'est
progressivement les amphithéâtres gérer
à l'abbaye à la recherche d'un bouquin
qui pouvaient synthétiser tous mes cours
de droit en vain avant le thé d'eads
midi j'avalais rapidement et
difficilement un sandwich au thon du
crous vous savez celui dont je parle
le tout sec là mais le plus terrible ce
n'était pas de voir le dernier sneakers
bloqués dans le distributeur
on a tous vécu ce drame non c'était ce
côté machinal toutes mes journées se
ressemblent et je ne trouvais rien dans
mon quotidien à l'université qui
pouvaient manille mais l'université ne
servait donc qu'à former les
travailleurs de demain n'est ce pas mais
qu'en est-il de soi on est formaté dans
l'idée qu'ils étudiaient mène à
travailler parce que travailler subvient
aux besoins
quand j'étais petit quand on me
demandait quel métier je voulais faire
plus tard je leur disais je veux être
marchand de glace parce que j'aimais les
glaces tout simplement
et visiblement
je les aime toujours puis j'ai grandi et
successivement j'ai rêvé d'être
comédienne critique gastronomique claire
chazal
avocate sent pas le seul film non puis
ministre de la culture le chômage
endémique et structurelle est une des
premières craintes des jeunes ils
partent d'emblée avec cette pression
sociétale qui pèsent sur chacune de
leurs années d'études
s'ajoute à cela la déconsidération
permanente des aînés à la jeunesse
allant jusqu'à nos caractères et de
cerveaux lobotomisés par la téléréalité
et les jeux vidéo c'est généralement
tous ces préjugés qui nous entoure et
auquel on doit faire face nous ne sommes
pas cette jeunesse lasse et désenchanté
nous n'appartenons pas à cette culture
du vide qu'il dénonce trop souvent nous
sommes cette nouvelle génération qui
était la charnière de deux époques deux
mondes entre l'ancien monde et le
nouveau celui de l'ère numérique
nous sommes aussi cette nouvelle
génération qui ne parvient pas à se
défaire du poids de l'histoire une
histoire qui bien souvent est méconnu
nous sommes une génération qui vit
plusieurs crises à la fois et qui
s'entremêlent entre crise économique
crise environnementale crise sociale
crise austère et surtout une crise
culturelle parce qu'au fond il est là
tout le problème
nous vivons une véritable prise de la
culture la jeunesse aujourd'hui
s'ignorent ne sait plus qui allaient où
elle veut aller
elle fait face à ce monde d intégrer
sans savoir comment agir et avec qui et
dans toute cette hystérie
comment se trouver comment se réaliser
quand on nous pousse rejet le rejet de
l'autre
le rejet de ce qui nous constitue le
rejet de nos origines d'une partie de
son histoire
je suis franco palestinienne je suis né
en france
mes parents viennent de palestine de
gaza j'ai la double nationalité et je
porte fièrement cette identité malgré de
plus conflit qui l'entourent j'ai eu la
chance d'avoir été élevé dans une double
culture extraordinaire et merci maman
merci papa je parle français et arabe
[Applaudissements]
je vis de ces deux cultures sans me
perdre encore une fois c'est la culture
qui me sauve
je ne suis pas tenté de me perdre dans
ce conflit qui déchaîne systématiquement
les passions je n'ai jamais rien eu et
de ce que je suis je n'ai pas été
inquiété par le racisme
même si je sais qu'il existe et que la
france est traversée par une crise
identitaire sans précédent parfois les
jeunes font face à des crises internes
et externe difficile
ils se sentent rejetés par la société
parce qu'ils sont issus de l'immigration
et par conséquent réagissent avec
hostilité
c'est pourquoi il nous faut répondre à
toutes ces crises par la culture avec un
grand c
je me suis rapproché d'une association
les ambassadeurs de la jeunesse qui m'a
permis de me réaliser en tant
qu'étudiante j'ai trouvé un nouveau
souffle à mon quotidien à l'université
ma mission au sein de l'association est
de rendre plus accessible plus
compréhensible la culture notre action
est de veiller au rapprochement des
peuples et des sociétés par la culture
car la culture est ce qui ne constitue
en tant qu'homme c'est qu'il nous reste
du passé est-ce que nous continuons
d'enrichir au fur et à mesure du temps
en tant que jeune quand on écoute un
discours comme le mien on se dit c'est
bien beau tout ça ça fait limite
discours politique mais que faire
concrètement
et puis la culture la culture c'est un
vaste sujet on voit pas trop ce que
c'est at war on pense que ça se limite
au musée au livre et à briller en soirée
à faire genre devant les gens et je sais
de quoi je parle
mais qu'est-ce que cultiver son identité
le point de départ c'est soit logique
l'identité c'est tout ce qui se rapporte
à soi c'est notre relation avec
nous-mêmes cultiver son identité
c'est tout un concept de création moi
par exemple je suis passionné d'art et
de littérature mais je trouve qu'il n'y
a pas assez d'espacé pour s'exprimer
artistiquement et faire valoir son art
quand on est amateur
je suis donc sur le projet de créer une
plateforme collaborative une sorte de
vitrine où les artistes amateurs
pourrait librement s'exposer j'ai eu
l'idée de ce projet mais qui s'est
enrichi grâce à l'appui de l'association
ambassadeur de la jeunesse
je reviens un instant sur le fait de
travailler dans une association
c'est à titre gracieux généralement on
est bénévole c'est très prenant sa
demande de l'énergie et du temps qu'on
trouve pas forcément mais c'est à une
plus value incroyable pour soi à tel
point que je fais partie aussi d'une
autre association le prix littéraire des
grandes écoles et universités qui
promeut chaque année un nouveau roman de
la rentrée littéraire et qui en
parallèle de ce prix organise des
événements culturels dans paris en
collaboration avec différents musées
j'ai évoqué deux associations
mais en réalité il y à un million trois
cent mille associations actives en
france selon les chiffres du ministère
de l'éducation nationale et de la
jeunesse tout plus diverses et variées
avec pour objet des motifs impérieux
d'intérêt général comme la raclette la
protection de l'environnement la
coexistence des religions ou la défense
des animaux cultiver son identité c'est
aussi trouver sa cause
à ce sujet je discutais avec ma
meilleure amie chloé il ya quelques
jours et elle me disait qu'elle avait le
sentiment de ne pas pouvoir agir
concrètement pour la cause animale elle
et vegan elle sensibilise autant qu'elle
peut aller dans une association
mais elle considère que son action n'est
pas assez forte n'est pas assez
puissante
alors elle prend le temps de réfléchir
de méditer pour penser un nouveau projet
et trouver un but à sa vie rapport avec
ce qui la caractérise son amour pour les
animaux
c'est exactement ça je cultive et son
identité
prenez quelque chose qui vous anime au
plus profond que vous êtes cultiver le
de telle sorte à créer quelque chose on
a tous quelque chose qui nous fait
vibrer le dessin la musique le théâtre
le cinéma le make-up le foot la
nourriture peu importe au final vous
allez forcément à un moment donné de
votre vie trouvez votre voix
ne désespérez jamais et si ce n'est pas
maintenant c'est peut-être dans quelques
mois dans un an ou plus
c'est la persévérance dans le fait de se
chercher soi qui nous pousse à nous
réaliser et à produire aujourd'hui on a
entendu des jeunes entrepreneurs qui ont
réussi à partir de leur vécu à créer
quelque chose
moi je n'ai encore rien créé mais je
suis plein d'idées et j'ai l'envié
furieuse de toutes les réaliser
quand on est jeune la force de création
est intense fougueuse passionnée elle
nous prend
trip albert camus mon amant spirituel
préconisé qu'il fallait vivre et créer
parce que créer c'était vivre deux fois
alors choisissons de vivre doublement
merci à tous
[Applaudissements]